very scared yeah I got my pit bull with
a grab on to my goddamn German Shepherd
lockup you weren't getting that dog off
and I just slide a nice little snake my
hand in there get a choke in and choke
my dog right unconscious and yep did it
what I did that I did that maybe maybe
10 times maybe 10 times I did I'm not
showing doubt I [ __ ] out okay I choked
out my German Shepherd and the pit bull
more than 10 times have a little try
choking out a [ __ ] man wants to kill
you - a man a little different it's not
because you just get in there and you
just when you shut the air did the blood
off there you go to sleep it's not that
hard
what's this gen it says you can you can
choke out a dog oh yeah oh yeah I've
done it I got it I didn't know because
the problem was my [ __ ] dogs were
watching the Superbowl and this is when
my pitbull and my German Shepherd
started fighting me and my buddy Bob
we're all hanging out and all of a
sudden I just hear I hear I come in my
dogs have fought themselves to
exhaustion and they're covered in blood
they had they tried to kill each other
and they were so tired that they come in
and that would cost me sixteen hundred
three thousand dollars to get them all
fixed up so I would lose my [ __ ] mind
so I got to a point where they would
lock up on each other and I just choked
him out hmm
and I choke one off the other and the
other one would come to bite the other
one was a [ __ ] how long it take for him
to come - oh right away it comes to you
right away
I'm not joking oh it's Hanneman square
where the tanks rolled in when those
student demonstrations happened in 1989
hey is this weird so like at the airport
is it I'm not trying to be racial I'll
be there Panda Express and [ __ ]
no there that's like they laugh at that
yes like if you go to Italy's er pizza
yes there's a yes you can find all that
stuff in China as well but here's the
thing about China oh I'll say say
there's something about groupthink there
there's something about you when you get
there that's out that you you're given a
paper first of all you're given a phone
you can use this phone you can try to
control everything good luck using your
phone they block Google and you have to
do these routers and they block it again
but here here use our phone here you go
this is our dog let's go on and you can
use WeChat
which you have downloaded which is
controlled by the government so that's
good you don't you are given a piece of
paper if you are here in any way to
stage any kind of a political protest
your will be put in jail on time and I
know those kids that stole from them oh
yeah and [ __ ] loves balls son they
the Donald Trump had to get involved in
around and oh by the way if you're
Chinese and you are going to mount some
kind of protest you're gonna it's it's
not aa to people to live there what
Chinese you you you can disappear just
will go away you're not it's not you're
gonna have to have lawyers China is
China is a capitalist country for all
intents and purposes
China has it's not a totalitarian state
I don't know a lot about it I do not
know a lot about it wasn't there long
enough there's a lot of great parts of
China I know I know I'm saying I'm your
view you will never go back you're gonna
get up there I know but what you're
trying to say is view worst country
you've ever been to sir
no you're not trying to see it what
you're saying is I'm saying it was a
dumb no it's not dumb it's all you're
saying is [ __ ] that place am i right
it's a little crowded let's crowd I got
to clean this place stinky air tends to
be a little polluted smells like a fart
there's a little polluting I was like a
fart I'm gonna say I know your brain
thinking it smelled like a fart here's a
definitely too much construction was
everyone baking fresh cookies no never
farting there's a lot of ones not garlic
in the food your phone that's kind of
right now [ __ ] why that's China god no
photo uploads all dead dead Yao Ming
jerseys float from the sky tail piece
that's moths uh what's up Jin what were
you saying you made me think of Panda
Express so there's a BuzzFeed video you
guys were watching BuzzFeed of course so
they're saying like what do Chinese
people think of Chinese food here and so
they're talking about Panda Express all
the younger kids the younger generations
are like oh no they're like no this just
doesn't really hit home it's not
whatever what Dad older Chinese people
like grandparents yeah
they tasted oh this is delicious like
orange chicken stuff probably gone
through the fam that the the famines of
the 60s also is being pretentious like
it's not Chinese food here's the other
thing you could go all over the world
give samples of orange chicken for
Pentos press out dear buddy loves it oh
so good everybody you go to Africa Egypt
China well off these land
please that's some of the toughest
people on the planet you don't chicken
and I'm one of them at the ethnic
Chinese could be back dude I've been
back in a while I had to have you back
pal yeah I think it's best tell me you
could live in Texas like you live in
Texas I wanna buy like a second home
there yeah that's my plan I could live
in Texas too maybe we could take our
business elsewhere
why because I wouldn't mind after my
kids living broke bags let me ask you
this honey I mean that's again sure bro
like in a timeshare home and just what
like that sort of family like a marble
countertop a kitchen we could bro we
have wood furniture and I pick cozy
blanket I don't know man I won Texas for
all that I mean you hit right on either
I'm just asking a question would we grow
our own food maybe man going on tricking
sex swing I said well if you're in LA
you know if you ever want to know places
to eat let me know and you know give you
my number he goes all right not even my
number but if I make a friend it's a
friend for life I'm just warning you sir
get her legs any okay well there it is
then I'll do you one better
I think I told you this they haven't
told audiences I'm at the economy store
this guy I'm gonna group with a group of
friendly tell this guy wants to talk to
me
grown man all of me 46:40 junkie goes
bro was last time you threw the football
around you excuse me as I was those
things you were ballin
all right but I don't know man use what
are you doing Saturday
oh wait uh probably with my family is
let's go to the park let's play catch
it's for the wrong road man let's throw
the wrong man and run some pattern let's
just let's just play cat let's do the
rock around it well well no no and I
thought he's joking around 30 is [ __ ]
you have to try to play catch another a
man
- a bit what by cat I could not stop
laughing I think you don't hydro chris
earley oh and he was in tears laughing I
went bro that guy just asked me to play
catch in pflueger's why what dead
serious he just asked why I want to go
the park on Saturday play camp probably
thought you wanted to work off some
cobwebs you know like get back to the
old glory days but that's what the best
is out of nowhere dude was less time
threw the rock around uh I could not
tell you let's play catch let's play
some catch we're doing Saturday not
playing catch with the Jews Saturday
I'll Drive up you know what you do is
alternate frisbee and then go [ __ ] each
other that's a good that's a terrible
idea
let's play some let's play some frisbee
kind of quiet about it guys we'll just
be like look with the girl girls get
detailed the girls will start whispering
I don't know what they're talking about
but they're there like they'll start
kind of like the look and then they'll
start conversing it becomes this energy
if they're all like they don't want
confirmation like are you you know yeah
they're all a titter over its got like
if I'm with my boys you know cars like
damn you see that purple GTS yeah
like can you see this then we all start
talking about it Mike I wanna I wanna
make sure everyone knows that the dope
car going by yeah well my wife was up
you with all your friends for this
charity I had Chris D'Elia get up it was
when he used to do the drunk girl well I
love that it goes back in time if they
were laughing the girls were laughing my
wife and her friends were laughing so
hard at that drunk girl thing they were
laughing so hard they were crying and
then they were all of them married and
then they all said in his head it
started become a Bieber there was a yeah
there was this but a gift that I was
watching this we were at each other and
talked and I was like yeah you and I
said a heads not Turkey she goes she
goes David they were all they thought he
was cute and they were they thought it
was hot the ones suck his dick I don't
know you want a son I don't think that's
I think what they say as they go
something like I like his pants and
what's his hair no there wouldn't work
on most people but it doesn't know then
there's always one [ __ ] in the group
like so and psycho I like his shoes I
like his necklace and then you hear what
the girl from second the city what was
the main surrett what's the main told
the [ __ ] slept with Samantha there's
always a Samantha new group yeah and
then the sir I like your shoes I kiss
teeth I wanna suck his dick like God
thinks I was like oh I would love no I
don't know starts going around and
that's like the one up and each no
that's not you know Chris is all off
foreskin is sucked yeah I got the rusty
trombone